Welcome back to human emotion.
Today we'll be talking about the
relationship between emotion and hormones
delving into the neuroendocrine system
and all its glory and mysteries.
As you can see here.
And in particular what we're going to
be doing by concluding with our third
segment on emotion and health is looking
at in what way do hormones actually
make us emotional? So when you think
of this as a common expression,
that hormones make you emotional,
but to what extent is empirical science
in the world of emotion actually support
this sort of lay notion?
Do emotions actually lead us to be more
hormonal and do hormones make us more
emotional?
So let's talk about hormones.
Let's first start by defining what
is a hormone in the first place.
So here you can see in Greek
hormone means to excite.
So stalling was the first of formally
define hormones as the chemical
messengers,
which speeding from cell to cell along
the bloodstream may coordinate the
activities and growth of
different parts of the body.
What is the function of hormones?
So we know that hormones bind to
specific receptors located throughout the
organism and they're involved in various
bodily processes such as reproduction,
digestion, growth, metabolism, mood,
cell death or survival,
as well as immune responsivity among
the whole broad host of functions.
So what's important to know is that
there's three main categories or types of
hormones,
so we have steroid hormones,
androgen estrogens and glucocorticoids.
We have peptide hormones such as
Vasopressin, oxytocin and insulin,
and then we have monoamine hormones such
as norepinephrine and epinephrine. Okay,
so steroid hormones, peptide
hormones, and Mondo mean hormones.
What evidence do we have though,
for interactions between
hormones and behaviors? Right?
Especially those we're going to think
about as we delve into this lecture today
that may be relevant to emotions,
so we know that hormone only dependent
behavior should disappear when the source
of the hormone disappears,
right?
We should also see that when you restore
that missing hormone or hormone source,
then that should restore the behavior.
We should also see that the
hormone concentration and
behavior frequency should
positively correlate with one another.
In other words,
is the hormone concentration goes up.
The frequency of that given behavior,
we think to be associated with
the hormone should also increase.
So we've talked about what a hormone is,
what its function,
what are the different types of hormones,
and what evidence we should see a
scientist to suggest that there is a
relationship between a hormone,
any given behavior.
But how do we collect hormone data?
So there's three different ways we do it.
And the bottom line here is that many
of our common bodily fluids contain
hormones.
So the most common way to collect
hormonal data is to do it through saliva.
And this is most commonly done of ease.
Um,
so participants will spit saliva into a
tube and you'll then be able to look at
its contents for different kinds
of hormone level concentrations.
The second method is blood collection,
though it must be collected with a
sterile needle and done by a certified
technician or phlebotomist.
Um,
so it's a bit more complicated when it
comes to the feasibility of collecting
these particular types of data.
The third is urine,
so it's similarly reliable to
blood, um, but it's cheaper, easier,
and noninvasive.
So how do you store data
once you collect it?
So what's really important when it comes
to collecting hormone data is that it
must be frozen quite
soon after you collected.
And the storage temperatures
are incredibly cold, so
negative 20 degrees Celsius,
and then you must analyze it
within four months of freezing.
So you've got to put it
in the freezer right away,
keep it cold and then analyze
it pretty quickly. Um,
interestingly you also see what are called
super cold or super low freezers that
are negative 80 degrees Celsius.
And these are used if you need to keep a
particular sample longterm or what they
call archival storage. And if you
do this, you have no limit on,
on storage length.
Yeah.
And then the idea of scoring
hormones or an assay.
So hormone levels are determined
if you're looking at saliva,
blood or urine by a process
called Radio Immuno Assay.
So unless your lab is
certified for benchwork,
you have an entire lab
devoted to this process.
Most psychology labs we find often will
ship these frozen samples to independent
labs to score them.
And what you'll get and once you send
your samples out is you'll get a nice
spreadsheet back with numbers that are
ready to conduct statistical analyses on
your hormone of choice.
So I spent some time going through
background of what is a hormone,
what is the function,
you know,
how do we relate it to behavior and how
do we collect it and score it so that
now we can be in a better
position to start our roadmap,
where we're going to talk about two
broad domains of hormones that's in
critically important
for emotion functioning.
This includes stress
hormones and sex hormones.
So we'll go through these two categories
today and then we'll conclude with our
takeaway questions and expert interview.
So let's start first now
with stress hormones.
Okay,
so stress,
we talked about this in a recent lecture,
but let's revisit what is stress?
So stress has been defined as the degree
to which people have to change and
Rayanne readjusts in order to
maintain their sense of homeostasis.
So stress can be either psychological
or it can be physiological and it can
either be acute,
so very time limited and brief or can be
more chronic sort of spanning a longer
duration of time.
When it comes to psychological stress,
it is defined as the degree to which
people have to change and readjust their
lives in response to an externally event.
And as we spoke about and
one of our earlier lectures,
stress need not be necessarily
associated with a good or bad event,
but we can see stress occurring in all
kinds of situations ranging from is
widely from weddings to funerals,
to graduations,
all of these types of events or sources
of potential psychological stress.
When we think of physiological stress,
by contrast,
it's been defined as the degree to which
your body has to regulate its processes
in order to maintain a type
of physical homeostasis. Okay,
so these are two different broad types
of stress and when we think of stress we,
there's kind of two different
kinds of major stress axes.
So we have the hypothalamic pituitary
adrenal access or what's called the HPA
axis.
So the HPA access releases glucocorticoid
such as cortisol in response to
stress. And you also have what's called
the Sam access or the sympathetic adrenal
Medulla Larry Axis. And this releases
catecholomines in response to stress.
So these are kind of our two main
kinds of stress axes or systems.
Let's start with cortisol.
So this is one of the most widely known
unpopular I stress hormones that's been
utilized across a whole variety of
different types of studies in the field of
psychology and specifically in
the field of emotion. So Cortisol,
what is cortisol?
So it's a catabolic stress
hormone regulated by the
HPA axis that we just talked
about a moment ago.
And in terms of action,
what it does is it helps metabolize
lipids and muscle tissue in order to help
release glucose.
And what it can measure then when it
comes to psychological parameters is acute
stress.
So you can look at Cortisol reactivity
by looking at what are called phasic
changes from one time point to another.
So from someone's resting
baseline measured by saliva.
And you can also then look at these
levels of saliva that reflect cortisol
released 18 minutes earlier.
So you can see phase it changes in
reactivity from baseline in response to a
stressor.
But what's really important to know is
that cortisol doesn't react right away.
And then what you're likely to see in the
saliva is reflecting cortisol that was
released approximately
18 to 20 minutes earlier.
You can also look at chronic
stress through the use of cortisol.
Here you can look at what's called
the cortisol awakening response.
So you can look at the trajectory of
Cortisol and hour upon waking. Um,
and you can also look at what's
called hair cortisol. So these are,
if you actually sample someone's hair,
you can see their average cortisol
levels over the previous four months.
So it's almost crazy to think that we
show signs of stress physically in our
hair and that it's a marker of how much
stress we've undergone the previous four
months of our life simply by
looking at a strand of hair.
Now I want to move to d. H. E. So
this is an anabolic stress hormone,
also released by the HPA access and
it's action is to protect against tissue
damage caused by cortisol by
promoting healing and tissue growth.
So it measures reactivity of sulfate
of Dha, EPA, also known as Dha,
EPA posture, be s and that phasic
changes. You can look at from baseline,
also measured in the saliva.
And similarly it's reflecting levels
that were released 18 minutes earlier.
And you can also look at what's called
the anabolic balanced by looking at the
ratio of Dh s to cortisol as well.
And then there's the alpha amylase.
So here,
this is a catabolic stress
hormone released by the Sam
access as opposed to the
HPA access. And what this particular
stress hormone does is it met,
helps us to metabolize starches in
the blood as well as brain sugars.
And the key measure is often looking
at reactivity in this particular stress
hormone. So again, you can look
at phasic changes from baseline,
measured in the saliva,
but here you've got a shorter time window.
So when you look at levels of saliva,
you're seeing amounts of the stress
hormone that were released five minutes
earlier.
So we've talked a bit about stress
hormones and what I want you to take home
here is that cortisol has been the most
popularized of all of them thus far and
is typically measured
using saliva samples.
And you can look at it both to measure
acute stressors. So sort of Phasic,
reactivities stressors in a lab situation
as well as more chronic or longterm
stress by looking at the cortisol,
awakening response and even measuring
hair related cortisol releases.
What I want to turn now though,
is to look at sex hormones.
So we have three different categories of
stress hormones. We have testosterone,
we have extra dial as well as oxytocin.
So let's walk through each of these.
So when we start with testosterone,
we know that testosterone is an anabolic
sex steroid synthesize in both the
testes and ovaries.
And we know that tonic or sort of baseline
levels of testosterone are related to
dominant behavior.
So this is really interesting.
We think about emotion because my
Disney associated with socially dominant
categories of emotion,
like pride for example.
It's also associated with the
regulation of the HPA stress,
access during dominance related tasks,
and of course as related as many of us
think about in terms of sexual libido,
both for men and women. Interestingly,
when we think about, again,
emotional behavior and in the
realm of social dominance,
we see phasic increases in testosterone
after people win competitions.
So we might think about this as an index
of dominant related behavior. And again,
I think of the discrete emotion of pride,
which is associated with displaying
one's elevated status within a social
hierarchy.
So can we think of testosterone is helping
us gauge specific kinds of emotions
that are related to elevating one's
sense of self status or experiencing some
sort of social class distinction of
one being more socially dominant than
another. These are some
interesting questions that
are currently being explored.
What we have seen when you look at
testosterone in situations of social
competition is that you see phasic
changes in testosterone after competition.
So while winners of a competition show
an increase in testosterone losers show a
decrease.
So we're seeing also testosterone change
in terms of whether people experience,
you know,
rewards or losses as well.
So it's sensitive to the type of stimuli
that is emotionally laden as well as an
environment too.
So reward we've talked about in this
course as being associated with a whole
type of positive approach related emotions
and loss as being associated with a
type of negative withdrawal
related emotions as well.
Now here we think of estrodial.
So this is an antibiotic sex steroid
metabolites from testosterone and tonic
levels are related interestingly to
positive mood and lower levels are related
to the experience and
severity of mood disorders.
Now interestingly,
if we turn to Oxytocin,
we also see that head has wide reaching
implications for emotion as well.
So oxytocin is a neuropeptide that doubles
as a hormone and there's been a lot
of research on oxytocin as what they
call the love hormone or the attachment
hormone.
So we see it associated with a whole
host of affiliate of types of behaviors
between people. So it's really set these
kind of key social attachment events.
So sexual climax,
but also childbirth and nursing
in a monogamous mammals.
It coworkers with dopamine receptors
in the brain and it actually increases
trust among strangers.
So there's been experimental studies
showing that if you can manipulate the
levels of oxytocin people experience
sometimes their intra nasal spray,
they'll actually trust other people more.
So it's a sense in which it sort of
brings us and binds us socially to other
people.
So hence has been called the love hormone.
And if we think about how might this
be relevant to our emotional lives?
Well we've talked about a whole variety
of different distinct classes of
emotions thus far.
And you might think about some of the
socially relevant or prosocial emotions.
And to what extent do motions
like compassion, love,
maybe even gratitude.
To what extent can we look at these in
conjunction with levels of oxytocin?
So these are some of the exciting
empirical questions that are being
investigated by aspect
of science researchers,
is how can we look at some
of these hormones we've
talked about today and relate
them to some of the key kinds of emotions
and they're distinct functions that
we've talked about thus far in this class.
And how can we think about the
measurement of hormones through
neuroendocrinology as a really important
and novel tool in our repertoire?
So we've talked about
subjective reports of emotion,
outward displays of expressive behavior,
neuroimaging.
To what extent can we now think about
leveraging insights from our understanding
of hormones and human behavior to even
better understand our emotional wellbeing
and regulation on another level.
So I talked about hormone state because
it's an exciting new methodological tool
that only recently have people in the
field of human emotion really tried to
grasp onto and to leverage,
to gain insights into how it might help
us understand our own emotional makeup.
So with that, we've talked a
little bit about stress hormones,
a little bit about sex hormones,
talked at the end about what kinds of
potential empirical insights we can gain
from this.
And again,
these are sort of novel cutting edge
tools that were only recently beginning to
apply to the study of emotion.
So want you to think about as a student
or someone who's interested in emotion,
how might you use these tools to better
understand emotions ranging from pride,
compassion,
gratitude,
as well as social bonding and how
emotions help subserve that function.
So with that, I'm going to turn
now to our takeaway questions.
Our first question asks,
what is a hormone and what are the
specific types of hormones that were
discussed at the beginning
of our lecture today?
And in what way can you try to conduct
data collection if you're someone
interested in scientifically measuring
and collecting these data samples.
Second,
what are the distinct stress hormones
that were discussed today and what does
each of their respective functions?
Okay,
what are the distinct sex hormones that
were discussed today and what does each
of their respective functions as well?
Yeah.
Now I want to turn to
our expert interview.
This is part of our experts in emotion
interview series today for experts in
emotion interview. We have the honor of
speaking with doctor [inaudible] Mehta.
So Dr Mehta is currently an assistant
professor of psychology at the University
of Oregon.
He received his Ba from Williams college
and his phd in social personality
psychology from the
University of Texas at Austin.
Before starting at the
University of Oregon as faculty,
he completed postdoctoral
fellowships as a Columbia University,
as well as Erasmus University and the
Donders institute in the Netherlands.
His research examines the psychological
and biological processes that help
regulate status,
hierarchies and decision making.
So I now turn to a very special experts
in emotion interview together with Dr
[inaudible] Mehta on emotion and hormones
and upcoming and very exciting field.